everything man i'm about to drop a
cookbook a raw vegan cookbook you know
so i guess i'm a chef now too
so explain the raw
part because some people say they're
vegan but when i just talked to you
about it you were like no i eat
everything raw now so what does that
mean it's just electric foods you know
like a lot of times when you cook your
food over a certain um temperature you
cook out all the nutrients so
um it's something that's kind of new for
me but
i like it because you know your whole
life you learn how to cook a certain way
right and then when you can't do that
anymore it forces your mind to create
new ways to do it and the the cookbook
thing was just like a lot of my [ __ ]
who like
in the hood don't know how to cook don't
know right yo raw is too expensive like
an easy applicable way to make raw
dishes that look good that tastes good
that make you feel good for like under
ten dollars you know so is raw like
essentially you go to the store you buy
vegetables
and then you just eat them that way
yes but you don't just you don't just
take some collard greens just eat them
right so like a vegan dish would be i
mean a raw dish would be like you get a
collard green right and then you get
some hummus you put some hummus in it
you chop up some onions you put a little
dill on it you cut up some garlic uh you
add some uh
you know it's just playing with flavors
so then you roll that up i like make
this like raw sushi i roll it up and it
just tastes incredible man little sesame
seeds in it some as opposed to like
cooking
opposed to the food yeah i've lost
12 pounds in about two weeks oh that's
big and so this is something new you you
just started i'm like 30 days in you
know i'm going to my birthday
because i love i love meat pause like i
love i love
i love me me too man you know that's why
i can never i just i i respect people
who say they're vegan yeah because i
couldn't i just can't even process
but it depends on how much you value so
when i eat meat and i'm like just a
[ __ ] carnivore i'm tired all the time
i'm [ __ ] sleeping in meetings i can't
move you know i mean i'm like in this
constant state of like narcosis right
so but i'm eating good right but now i'm
raw and it doesn't really [ __ ] with like
eating some ribs or some jerk chicken
but i stay up 19 hours out the day i can
run [ __ ] as long as i want to
you know i just feel incredible i feel
amazing are you good so after your
birthday you're going to go back to
eating meat
no on my birthday i'm going to eat a
dish a dish a dish what would that dish
be
like some grade 8 wagyu [ __ ] you know
just top maybe like thousand dollar
filet wagon
[ __ ] the wagos the one yeah that's the
wagon yeah
that's a nice way to treat yourself yeah